justin is whether some Rochester
Minnesota hi Justin how are you good are
you Dave better than I deserve what's up
well I just have a question for you
about debit cards and an Apple pay so
it's kind of a two-part question
on the tip cards of the nations and with
all the fraud out there what is the most
secure way to run your debit card
through when you're shopping in a real
real upset retail store like using a pin
or pressing the credit button to run it
like a credit card and then also do you
know if Apple pay is just as secure or a
more secure payment method if attached
here debit card well it's still running
through your debit card whether it's
Apple pay or PayPal or whatever and so
you know you've got you know two or
three points of data breach that are
potential if you refuse your credit card
at Home Depot and Home Depot has a data
breach
I mean Marriott just had a data breach
sent 500 million names and pieces of
data lost came out last week okay
and so you you know didn't matter if you
paid for it by Apple pay or whether you
paid for it with PayPal or whether you
paid for it with your debit card at the
front desk or your credit card the front
desk
you just got breached so that's because
the the vendor did that the chip cards I
mean if you're if you're on a chip card
right now and you hit your your PIN it
generally doesn't go through the ATM
system it with a chip card it's going
through the credit card system it just
keeps you from you can run it either way
but the visa is backing it either way
now if it's through an ATM visa does not
back it but if it is a debit card
transaction it's treated exactly the
same way for fraud protection that
credit cards are exactly go to visas
website they have a zero liability
policy it's stated clearly on their
website you just look it up it takes
about three minutes to find it and it
says we want you to enjoy the security
of both your credit card or your debit
card and you have a 100% coverage for
fraud or theft when using your card ID
theft and so online purchases are
perfectly
with either one as far as identity theft
goes now you can do business with a bad
vendor and either card you're gonna have
a problem with you're gonna have to
dispute and go through all that but you
can dispute a debit card just like you
can dispute a credit card and you know
the merchants you have to go back and
forth with a merchant and the credit
card provider have to go back and forth
with the merchants so overall there's
just no difference between a credit card
and a debit card except you may be short
of cash for a few days while you dispute
this but ultimately at the end of the
beat at the end of the day
you got the same coverage